I message needs to be engaged in the
issue of climate change humans aren't
causing it but humans are so
exacerbating a natural trend that what's
happening is that the earth cannot
respond to it in the way that has it we
are seeing species damage we're seeing
all sorts of issues that come from it
and we haven't had the chance to adapt
so the idea of slowing it down is an
important one we're not going to stop it
I don't believe that that should be a
goal it's not practicable it's not
possible but we do need to start taking
some action now so that we can mitigate
the worst of the potential damage and I
be able to react to it and have in place
other positions and other policies that
allow us to continue to grow
you